-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy and Tony
Award-winning actor
you know from movies like
"Moulin Rouge!",
"Ice Age," and "Encanto."
He stars in "The Menu,"
which is in theaters
November 18th.
Let's take a look.
-Do you need assistance
finding your seat?
-There's a finger right there.
-The man is screaming in pain.
-Please. Sit.
[ Man sobbing ]
-Not funny, lady.
Jesus Christ.
-It's all part of the menu.
-Oh, my God.
-This is real, isn't it?
Can't do it. I can't --
I can't do a hostage --
-Then why don't you
go talk to him?
Go talk to him.
Because you know him, right?
-I made that up.
-Why?
-Because I'm a name-dropping
whore. That's why, okay?
-Please welcome back
to the show our friend
John Leguizamo, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me back.
-I was lucky enough
to see you on Monday
at the premiere of this movie,
which I loved a great deal.
One of our writers here
at "Late Night"
was a co-writer on this film.
Seth Reiss.
-Seth Reiss.
-You got to meet Seth
and work with Seth.
How was your time with him?
-A lot of time with him.
Well, he wrote
this character for me --
this egotistical actor.
And he knows about egotistical,
you know,
because you know Seth himself.
He's kind of egotistical.
-Oh, I thought you were saying
he knows egotistical
because he writes for me.
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
-Very self-revealing of you.
-You get to be -- You do play
an egotistical actor.
Did you base it on anything,
actors that you've worked with
over the years?
-You know, it's funny
that you should ask that
because I play
a washed-up action star.
And I've worked up
with a lot of action stars
that are washed-up now.
And there was one
in particular that I --
that I like to use,
and that's Steven Seagal.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
So that's who I based it on.
-That's great.
I kind of want to go watch it
a second time now.
-You see that, yeah. The hair.
I did the hair kind of like him.
Painted scalp
and stuff like that.
-Did you actually -- Did you
work with him on a movie?
-Yes, I did.
"Executive Decision."
-Okay.
-And I was playing
his right-hand man,
and he knocked me out
in rehearsals.
-Oh, wow. By accident?
-Oh no, no. On purpose.
-Wow!
-Because I was laughing at him,
'cause -- As I tend to do.
I do laugh at people.
I don't take anybody seriously,
not myself.
But I was laughing at him,
and he elbowed me so hard
in the solar plexus.
Knocked me against the wall.
I hit the wall,
and I slid down and --
-Wow!
-Yeah.
But he dies in the movie.
So I was there the first --
I was the first one there
to see him die.
Even though it was fake,
I still --
-It's very nice for you
to come and watch
while other actors work, yeah.
This is a great film.
You obviously are working --
I think the first time
you were on the show,
I talked about, you know,
I know you from one-man shows.
That was the first time
I saw you.
And now you're doing a new one
that is actually going to be
a musical one-man show,
which I'm --
-It's not a one-man show.
I'm sorry.
"Kiss my Aztec"
is my new musical.
-Okay, gotcha. "Kiss my Aztec."
All right.
-But I can't sing.
-Oh, so that's why you need
more man in the show?
-Yeah, exactly.
I need a lot more people in
the show because I can't sing.
I mean, I've got a great voice.
I just can't hit
a melody or a pitch.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's a beautiful voice.
And, yeah, it's coming
to Broadway next year, yeah.
It's a real funny take
on conquest and genocide.
-Oh, that's good. Well --
[ Laughter ]
-Fodder. Fodder for humor.
Yeah.
-If there's any pair of hands
I feel like that might be
safe in, it's yours.
-Yeah, yeah, no, I handle it.
I handle it.
-You were Bruno in "Encanto."
-Yes, yes. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
-Now, you know,
obviously you've done
animated films before.
But to be the sort of --
the title character in the song
that was what everybody was
singing for the course of --
-It was a crazy hit.
-What was it like?
-Oh, my God. It was incredible.
First, Lin-Manuel
calls me up and goes,
"John, I wrote a rap for you."
And I go,
"Oh, my God, he wrote a rap!
I'm going to be in a movie!"
Then the poor guy suffered
because he had to spend hours
and hours trying
to get me into pocket.
Because I cannot sing.
So he suffered a lot.
But you know,
parents recognize me,
and then they, like, want me
to meet their kids and go,
"This is Bruno,"
and then it never goes well.
-The kids --
-They don't get it.
They don't like it.
-They don't like it.
They see this mug and they go,
"Oh, no, not so cool.
He's not really Bruno."
-Yeah. It is really funny.
They're like,
"You know the clean lines,
the clean animation lines
of your beloved character?
He's actually a real grown man."
-Yeah. With whiskers.
Funny-looking man.
-You have this movie
I've been seeing trailers for
with the great David Harbour
called --
-Oh, my God. He's so good.
-..."Violent Night."
This is coming out. This seems
like the kind of Christmas
film that
we haven't seen before.
-Oh, hell yeah.
This is an anti-Christmas movie
for Christmas.
Like, people who hate Christmas
movies, this is your movie.
Because he's a badass.
He drinks. He curses.
He punches people out.
He pisses from his reindeer --
flying reindeer.
-Gotcha.
The Santa
we've been waiting for.
-Yes.
-The Santa For this era.
And I'm going to go on a limb
and say David --
a better action movie costar
than Steven Seagal?
-Oh, he never hurt me.
We had a big fight sequence.
50-punch fight sequence,
and he never hurt me.
I love that man.
-That's a gentleman.
-Yes, sir.
-You know, in "The Menu,"
you play an actor
who's about to embark on
doing a reality show,
which you're actually doing
in real life.
John Leguizamo.
What's the show?
It's going to be on MSNBC,
right?
-It was a little weird
because -- you know,
It's a washed-up movie star
who's using the Food Network
to revitalize his career.
Then -- "Wait a minute. I'm
working on a Food Network show."
Is my career washed-up?
I mean, I was never
an action star,
so I can't be
a washed-up action star.
Anyway, yes. Anyway, but this
is beautiful, for MSNBC.
It's about Latin culture.
And I go across
all of America --
a docuseries,
exploring Latin culture.
Chefs, singers, artists,
activists, politicians.
-Have you shot it yet?
-Yes, we shot six episodes.
-Now, I have to ask you this.
Because I did exactly
one episode of one travel show.
-And what happened?
-It was the most exhausting --
I think they look so fun.
-Oh, my God.
-It's so tiring, right?
-Oh, you said it.
My God.
It's the most exhausting --
-You're so full all the time.
They make you eat so much.
-And you got to keep eating
because sometimes
you make mistakes,
so now I gotta eat
a whole new what?
That didn't come out right?
I got to eat that whole
lechon again? Oh, my God.
And you got to enjoy it.
-All things considered,
that's why --
I'm surprised
you've already done it,
because I assumed you'd be
a full 100 pounds heavier.
-Oh, I was 100 pounds heavier.
-You just worked it off?
-Yeah, yeah, I've been fasting
since they shot it,
been fasting for six months.
-We talked about, you know,
obviously both a film actor
and a stage actor.
In your early days, you loved
the idea of going to shows.
Didn't quite have the money
to do it. How do --
Explain how you would find
your way into Broadway theaters.
-Yeah, well, you know,
I was broke, I was ghetto.
I was -- you know,
but I loved theater.
But it was unaffordable
for a poor guy like myself.
So I would do this thing
called "second acting."
Have you ever done that?
-No.
-I guess -- Well, now people
will know how to do it.
Back then, there was none
of that digital-ticket stuff,
and people smoked a lot,
so I would wait
for the second act
when all the smokers
would come out,
and I would dress up
with my best polyester suit,
and I'd bring cigarettes.
I was too young to smoke,
but I would smoke anyway.
And I'd grab a playbill
that was on the ground.
And you run in.
-Ah!
-With all the smokers,
and you run in.
And I look down,
and then you go to the bathroom,
and you wait for everybody
to sit down.
And then you run back out
and you sit in the empty seats.
-That's amazing.
-And I saw "Elephant Man."
I saw "Waiting for Godot."
I never saw the first act.
Which is probably better
for "Waiting for Godot."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, ultimately --
It's still just
a lot of waiting.
-Always. Yeah.
Existential waiting.
-During the second act
of "Waiting for Godot,"
did you turn
to other people and go, like,
"Did anything happen
in the first act?"
-I was always afraid
of talking to people
because they'd turn me in
or something.
-Yeah. Well, a very novel idea.
Obviously, it paid off
down the line.
And thank you for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Thank you for having me,
brother.
-"The Menu"
is in theaters this Friday.
And "Violent Night"
opens December 2nd.
We'll be right back
with Zoe Kazan!